ciao English on the menu today is
abalone with lemongrass it's Friday and
that's Asian cuisine day two teachers
are explaining how this delicacy is
prepared the students are budding chefs
the Academy of culinary arts Cambodia
was founded by swiss-born social
entrepreneur Pierre Tommy
I've been in Cambodia for 27 years I've
been running a number of social
enterprises in the food and beverage the
number of restaurants a large catering
business and we see like everybody else
we cannot invest more and do more or
even create more jobs because the
bottleneck is skills the school in Phnom
Penh opened its doors in April financial
aid is available to students from poor
families such as 23 year old Madhavan my
parents died when I was 11 then I went
to live with my aunt she has five
children so I had to look after my
brothers now I'm here training to be a
chef
learning basics such as how to fill it
of fish which knife should be used and
even where to leave it when the job's
done the rules and techniques are new to
many students for example pasta and so
on they can't do that yet they don't
know how to prepare it and steam and
roast Italian style so it's a major
challenge opening the school was a labor
of love for Pierre Tommy he's confident
that a solid chef's training will be of
massive benefit to young Cambodians
hardly any chefs in the country are
officially qualified he's hoping the
school will expand but there are many
hurdles to clear sometimes we find pipes
the wrong size the wrong Heights we find
the electrical points that don't work so
it's a it's very time-consuming so we
have to be very patient Pia Tommy has a
lot of patience and a lot of experience
here in Cambodia the school is located
in the center of Phnom Penh the tower
the Botanic tower stands as a
a sign that Cambodia has developed have
come a long way in recent years Cambodia
has seen strong economic growth of some
7% annually it's a young country but
there's little social security and young
people are expected to help support
their parents if they have a
qualification they're more likely to get
a job in the world a training program
like this that combines theory and
practice and even has an international
dimension to it is a novelty in Cambodia
any chef Michelin star or or Western
share for from Tokyo Singapore when he
comes here to show cooking to do
demonstration will find everything that
he has back home so we've equipped it
with the latest of technology from a
steamer to induction to sous-vide to
everything that modern kitchen would
have anywhere in the world he's not the
only one dreaming big 20 year old chum
Sakia wants to do his family proud
but Senor acting and I put my biggest
dream is to become a famous chef one day
and to run my own business what I'd
really like to do most is open a
Cambodian restaurants either in the US
or in Cambodia Tommy hopes to have 100
trainees by September when I hear the
kids why they came and they tell me I
want to start a business
I dream of a career in the culinary and
finally I can get a good certificate
that allowed me to work in five-star
hotel
that's excites me a lot because these
people are passionate and they have a
dream like I also have a dream without a
dream we don't do anything in this life
the school would never have opened
without donations from a number of Swiss
firms but in the long run it's supposed
to pay for itself
although there'll be some grant holders
the rest of the students pay three
thousand US dollars per semester and the
training takes two years and all of them
have to learn to tidy up after
themselves
Oh